I don't even remember the jokes but I
remember having fun with it right and
then I got off stage
and this guy walks up to me and he goes
whoa he goes who wrote those jokes
I said I did he goes he goes those are
funny he goes listen uh I know somebody
may want to write with you can I get
your phone number I said sure here's my
phone number and I forgot I'd even given
him my phone number
and he's I get a call a week or two
later and this guy calls me up he goes
can I speak to Byron
I go yeah this is Byron he goes this is
Jimmy JJ Walker and he's and Jimmy what
he's the hottest comic on the planet
Dynomite Dynomite this has got he's got
the number one sitcom Good Times
everybody's doing Dynomite he says my
man Wayne Klein that's who came up to me
he goes my man Wing Klein says you're
funny and if my man Wayne Klein says
you're funny then you must be funny and
I said oh tell Wayne I said hello and
thank you he goes yeah Wayne he's
sitting here with me and my writing guys
he goes Wayne Byron says hello so listen
he goes do you want to come over here
and write with me and my boys
and I go oh okay let me ask my mom
so then I hear Jimmy go oh my God he's
got to ask his mom and then I heard this
dude in the background say tell his mom
not to worry we'll have cookies and milk
for him
and then Jimmy said Dave be nice be nice
right so my mother says yeah you can go
over Jimmy's apartment and you can write
with his writing team so she drops me
off on a Tuesday night at 7 30 at his
apartment which was about two or three
blocks from The Comedy Store
I'm 14 I walk in and sitting there is
Wayne Klein obviously Jimmy Walker it's
his place uh Jay Leno who was sleeping
in his car off the 405. wow uh David
Letterman who was literally sleeping in
a closet across the street from The
Comedy Store and he had just driven out
from Indianapolis in a red or an orange
pickup truck it was a weatherman it was
a weatherman at wish in Indianapolis he
didn't think he was going to make it so
he drove out so he could drive back he
thought he was going to turn the car
back around the the truck the pickup
truck and he stood out okay orange red
pickup truck in LA on Sunset and Marty
Nadler who went on to write and produce
Laverne and Shirley and happy days and
Jeff Stein and Wayne Dugan a lot of
amazing right but Leno and Letterman and
JJ and this kid and we're in we're in
Jimmy's apartment and Leno and Letterman
were getting 200 a week and at one point
Jimmy Walker managed all of us
he managed us he used to manage he and
his partner oh yeah he and his his
managing partner managed Jay Leno David
Letterman me all of us and Jimmy was
saying look you don't want to be a
comedian be a writer and at one point
had convinced David Letterman to be a
comedy writer and not a performer and
David was miserable and he was like okay
I can't handle this anymore and David
wanted to get out of his contract his
management contract and pursue his dream
of being in front of the camera Leno
went to Walker to get Letterman out of
his contract so Letterman could go and
pursue being in front of the camera it's
pretty amazing the story so they were
getting 200 bucks a week and I was
getting 25 a joke
yeah so I sold my first joke to so all
you needed was eight jokes nine jokes
you beat that to beat them and that's
what he told me that's what Walker said
you know I said I I remember asking
Jimmy can I get 200 a week like Leno and
Letterman he said no no he goes you can
get paid more than them I go really goes
just write me 10 jokes I'll you'll get
250.
[Music]